on s'était mis retombées du ciel
totalement tombé du ciel une fois une
fois qu on se convainc que c'est pas
dangereux
tellement là bas d'abord nous sommes
chanceux d'être venu nous sommes peu
nauséeux puis mais je suis sûr qu'ils ne
me surprend c'est l'odeur du foin ici
c'est super bon
dit des choses il a dit beaucoup de
choses a déjà beaucoup d'informations
david saint-jacques est donc revenu sur
terre les une fois qu'on s'est convaincu
que ça allait bien ben c'est très c'est
très amusant on va les voir tout de
suite avec un cas vécu cette expérience
à l'ex astronaute canadien bob thirsk et
avec tout ce matin bonjour bonjour
manger pour vivre ça vous citez c'était
il ya dix jours vous avez les rats bien
vous en souvenez alors il sens commun
dans le moment lui
oui c'est les effets de la gravité d'un
produit encore la force de gravité
contre le corps humain il ya beaucoup
des choses qui changent dans le corps
humain dans le puits dans l'espace et
maintenant je vois que d'avesnes souffle
les mêmes problèmes médicaux que j'ai
souffrir pendant dix ans à lui c'est la
nausée qu'il est un peu ce matin se
nomme d'ailleurs les préposés russes
sont arrivés avec trois sacs pour les
trois astronautes
donc c'est normal que quelqu'un réagisse
comme ça oui c'est normal parce que
marc-andré le système vestibulaire notre
système de balance de aux hésitations
est en vacances pendant six mois et
maintenant à être introduit en cours à
la gravité et pour ses prisons david
souffre de l'étourdissement oui et aussi
de problèmes avec l'impression de
sangles le cas encore en vacances
pendant six mois souffre d'une faiblesse
maintenant est ce difficile de contracté
la lèpre le que pour maintenir la
pression du sang' arriver le second avez
vous des souvenirs précis vous aussi
quand c'est arrivé je crois que c'est
marc garneau s'est peut-être quelqu'un
d'autre qui disait qu'on avait bien peu
plus son téléphone cellulaire est juste
le vil téléphone cellulaire il était
lourd il était l'eau le téléphone
cellulaire
aussi après une telle mission j'ai eu le
problème de tenir une tasse de dos oui
et là c'est l'état dans l'air a le
réflexe pendant six mois c'est possible
de laisser les lunettes les stylos en
plein air et faire quelque chose d'autre
et le tracé et tout cela eh oui
adaptation wii au temps encore pour
david et j'ai eu une solide parce que
son réadaptation à exactement comme pour
moi comme on dit en bon français c'est
ex beau quand c est exactement comme on
leur enseigne
quand on voit ça y'a encore encore des
décennies après on encore la science
médicale fait encore du progrès pour
voir comment le corps réagit étudiait
beaucoup d'expériences médicales qu'il a
pu mener aussi les qui se font
régulièrement grâce à ses veaux la wii
le but de ces experts expérience et de
bien comprendre comment le corps change
dans l'espace et aussi de demander si
c'est possible pour les corps humains de
voyager plus loin dans l'espace le
prononce comme l'étourdissement les
faiblesses de la locker c'est un
problème de vision de couture et mais
maintenant nous pensons dès les missions
vers la planète mars une mission de deux
ans et demi et je suis inquiété pour les
problèmes de les muscles les autres et
aussi les choses et écologique
rousset et c'est pour cette raison la
plupart des expériences de david pendant
le dernier 6 7 mois et le but est de les
confirmer la possibilité de voler plus
loin dans l'espace
allez moi plus du psychologique parce
que là il est revenu sur terre
je pense qu'il prend l'avion presque
maintenant pour rentrer chez lui il ya
cette euphorie de voir la famille
d'avoir vu la planète
ça va lui manquer il voit de retour sur
terre il va faire un peu un autre genre
de travail qu'elles ont de débriefing on
doit avoir ou de suivi psychologique
quand on revient d'après ma mission de
six mois
j'ai maintenant des nouveaux perspective
de l'humanité de la civilisation en
l'occasion de voir toutes les terres
nous sommes une toute une population et
je suis fier d'être canadien mais
plusieurs
c'est plus important d'être un citoyen
du planet intel etc les choses pour moi
les choses important n'est pas les
laisser faire par exemple de la famille
kardashian les choses le plus important
pour moi c'est le égalité le dommage de
l'environnement quelque chose comme ça
c'est pour moi nous sommes tous humanité
tout connecté l'une et l'autre
on verra bien parce que on aura
certainement l'occasion de lui parler on
entendra parler de cette expérience le
pij paris que ça va être pas mal la même
chose connaissant l'homme se serait pas
surprenant qu'ils disent la même chose
que vous je te remercie beaucoup
d'univers ce matin mais c'est marc-andré
hockey aux voix au revoir